welcome to this video playing the same
guy again Renard Fletcher check Roland
or Ronald let me check this Roland okay
from from Switzerland and playing a bogo
chain or style to play this this new
line interesting line for black funny
honey mix off of variations yeah with
this capture and then they're d5 blacks
idea here is to play a quick castles and
rook the eight putting pressure on them
on the d4 pawn and white it's not so
easy for white to get the porn back yeah
this is a possibility yeah I have two
main ideas I can ignore it here or can
take I think this is probably a
situation where I take it yes played
look see one which is not helpful move
in all cases
still not clear how we will get the porn
back or what you will do with with this
okay yum F form i have i have various
ideas but I go with this this covers the
pawn and I wonder this check Mets just a
real chick and not not does not promise
very much but okay I can get in a loop
da to deserve this should be useful I
wonder I wonder if move like Bishop d7
SS any good just giving up the pony and
go for counter play even 95 as an idea
but what is this is grand plan yet I
don't really know okay I just prepared
Bishop d7 to c6 I mean maybe he he
really needs to to push this very hard
like g4 f5 those those kind of things I
just want to play Bishop c6 I mean I
don't mind the trigger porn I get the B
file and 95 those kind of ideas so
triple porn is not a big deal it's also
part of my extra pawn so mmm yeah just
Bishop c6 why not won't want to go there
anyway and I know I don't even get the
triple porn
this looks very nice i mean i don't see
any any great compensation for white and
i still have this pawn okay he just he
does not mind trading okay let's say i
take a txt five cake g2 yeah i have FB
seven hanging true but play king fa this
is very silly I'm just just covering the
Queen let's see Queen nor can II to
Queen a five maybe and then I probably
just heck this night off which I'm
threatening anyway check oh really it
goes for the Queen trade and then nights
if I feel that this is possible
definitely so um if I take this and play
look d5 this should be good right just
attack the the night it's not stable
peace on c5 if it retreats I play up the
aid and this is really just a pawn for
nothing
I mean yeah and night 97 next to get to
a rook endgame a pawn up this is a nice
way to play the the Catalan right you
just snatch this just and snatch to the
pawn and hold on to it maybe this wasn't
precise no but okay he I thought maybe
take sandy form maybe I am it still is a
pond but it could be it could be some
compensation it was not very precise
yeah d44 is not good cake and beehive
maybe check not it's not idea the sister
should have played better this is not
ideal he's got quite some activity now
that's a real shame he never goes should
have gotten that phone p 6
I want to go look be six maybe
yeah gee I'm a porn it's not worth much
yeah
yeah the plate that didn't play this
precisely at the beginning of the end
game I definitely didn't it started out
we're in a situation where he really had
no compensation but it it got to a point
where he definitely had check still
still try to trying to win here maybe
this is the risky risky proposition time
morning now this is the problem there's
some way to play for win here would see
five or something that's very risky
no I have no way to to avoid that game
drown yeah that's probably probably okay
I made a mistake right here I think 97
is not not well time TM it's not well
timed how do I play that better maybe
f6f 6am may be weakening weakening white
structure first at the moment there is
also on this issue that i can play t for
now now this is maybe where I can
improve after 97 maybe I'm abc6 is still
better yeah see six is better check c6
yeah this is this is the point ready now
this is better this also makes sure that
his King is not getting so active and I
should play f6 something like this
quickly no hit not f5 f6 breaking his
pawn structure yeah this is promising he
does not get this active a shank and
here with this active king he is
probably having enough compensation here
maybe a five I probably should prevent
before him yeah here he definitely has
enough play check he has enough play him
I have no way to avoid this now
have to cover antioch g7 is too strong a
thread i cannot i mean i cannot play
stuff like that i mean this is this is
crushing me really be a suicidal ok i
think ok game thanks for watching